foreign
doesn't believe in mental illness my
Asus score is a nine whoa oh you could
do probably like an entire series just
in my life your husband actually sounds
like a knight he's a nice guy he's
amazing okay and he's an idiot and those
two things can be true at the same time
[Music]
good morning good afternoon good night
whatever's going on in your world I'm so
glad that you've joined us on the Dr
John deloney show I'm John and we are
here for one reason
hope you have a better life
better marriage
help you get along with your kids a
little bit better help you figure out
what's going on in this
Wackadoo world
get some questions some honest answers
about your mental health and what's
going on whatever's going on your life
we're here to help and I'm so grateful
that you've joined us and I I just I'm
becoming overwhelmed by the countless
letters and notes and direct messages
all just the positive things people are
doing to change their life little bitty
things here and there picking up from
the show so thank you so much for being
with us I'm so grateful
um if you want to be on the show give me
a buzz
1-844-693-3291 and it makes all the
difference in the world
super weird but it makes all the
difference in the world if you will just
hit the Subscribe button
um oh if you listen to this on Apple
podcast or Spotify podcast if you will
subscribe to the Show YouTube subscribe
to the show
um leave great killer five star reviews
all that stuff helps so much helps all
across the board
um helped put this show in front of
people who have never heard of it whose
marriages are falling apart whose kids
are Bonkers who are struggling with
depression anxiety whatever and they'll
they would never have known about the
show otherwise and we got it in front of
them just because you took it one second
to hit subscribe so thank you so so much
to everybody who's doing that it means
the world let's go out to uh Sadie in
Yorktown Sadie what's up Sadie
hello how we doing
I'm good how are you we are rocking on
to the Breaking Dawn Sadie having a
party oh yeah
oh yeah what's up
um so first of all thank you for taking
my call of course um I've had a pretty
hearty year
um in your podcast and your show has I
watch every day and it's giving me some
awesome tips for dealing with my
childhood trauma and some things I
struggle with
um and so I had a question for you that
I think you can help me with well first
of all I'm sorry I've had a bum year and
the cool thing is we got nine more
months to go so we can turn this ship
around right and uh thanks for being
with us man it means it means the world
to me thank you so let's let's figure it
out let's do it what's up
okay so my question is my husband
doesn't believe in mental illness I have
been clinically diagnosed with OCD and
ADHD welcome to the gang yeah I know
that I'm unmedicated for so
um yeah trying to navigate that I was
diagnosed as an adult after I have my
children
um and I've also suffered through bouts
of depression
um how do I get him to understand these
are very real for me and affect my
day-to-day life
um even if I'm in agreement that I don't
not that I don't believe in mental
illness I don't think I'm broken
um a little bit of background my Asus
score is a nine one oh yeah so nine
a nine
yes sir God Almighty my husband is a
zero
um and we've been together since we were
15 and 17.
so I think there's been some times for
him where he's seen me as what he would
think in his mind is quote unquote
normal
um and now I'm 29 and a lot of this
stuff is resurfacing
um part of my bummy year is I lost my
dad unexpectedly last June I'm so sorry
um he had been an addict my entire life
and got clean 10 years ago
went back to college
um got a degree in addictions counseling
started a program here in our hometown
where he helped hundreds of families
um and he passed away in June from a
accidental fentanyl poisoning
oh man so did he have a relapse
um I'm yes and at first it's been
[Music]
it's the first and now it's been about
nine months and it's saying yeah we're
looking back at all of this and
he had relapsed and it's heartbreaking
because
I think he felt like he was the strong
person leading everybody and he's died
and what's happened is a lot of my own
trauma has resurfaced and affected me
but I'm also seeing a lot of
him and me yeah
and uh how old are your kids
um they are two and four yeah
and I would expect and I don't say this
to freak you out I say it's just just
just to be ready
um as your body begins to remember those
moments as your kids hit those
Milestones expect your body to try to
solve that again because it missed out
the first time around is gonna try to
solve it again now that you're you're
taller and you have bigger muscles right
yep yep and that's what I tell my
husband is Dr John always says like the
body doesn't forget yeah yeah especially
not with the nine
um yeah
there's so so much here
um
oh you could do probably like an entire
series just in my life well here's the
thing so
um your husband actually sounds like a
knight he's a nice guy
he's amazing okay Andy's an idiot and
those two things can be true at the same
time right okay good yeah and tell him
that I said that that's fine tell him he
sounds wonderful and he's a the
second thing is he would agree yeah
right the second thing is two things can
be true at the same time
um
that your dad
was absolutely in no shape when we're
fashioned the dad that he should have
been for you
and
that God loved you through the the foggy
lens of addiction
yeah right he loved his baby girl
yeah that's
that's stuff there that's right and
you'll never be able to have the
conversations that's right you can't you
can't yes
and so one of the devastating moments of
grief is being able to have those
conversations with The Ether
and even if you'd had him you know the
Sadie he wouldn't have heard him right
yeah and so all that to say is both of
those things are true at the same time
here's something else that's true
OCD and ADHD are very very real and yeah
they can't be the excuse by which our
life the the lives of those who love us
interact with us that we've chosen to be
in relationship with have to suffer
both of those are true also okay so what
you're you're holding this Paradox and
it's it's messy and those who love
people who struggle with addiction those
who struggle with mental health
challenges those who are married to
amazing people whose lives were pretty
greased
um moving forward pretty pretty
straightforward lives
um the Paradox the two sides of that
barbell are just the weight is really
heavy
yeah is that fair
yes and I want to put it down yeah there
we go there you go okay
um I'm gonna walk through a couple of
things because you and I like
um back when I was in the middle of all
this those were my two two of my main
clinical stamps okay ADHD and OCD okay
um
and interestingly I never my anxiety was
always an outflow of those things okay
yes um
if you use and I I'm speaking to you and
I'm also talking to the audience okay so
you may say that's not me at all this is
what I'm saying but I'm speaking
generally if you use ADHD and OCD as
excuses for not being a present or
direct or connected spouse
your husband's gonna have to go to war
with ADHD and OCD
yeah because some people some people
um when things are uncomfortable or
they're ugly or they're not the way they
should be
they go to war with reality
it's how a million people plus died of
covet and you still have people saying
that's not real that that was that was
the response sideways of course was
there all the nonsense with vaccines and
mass yes oh is covet super real yes
right and sure a whole swath of our
country didn't want to believe that so
they just went to war with reality
yeah if I'm married to someone who I
love deeply and I've been with her for
half of her life or more and then she
tells me there's this thing that keeps
her from being on time from paying
attention to me to being able to put her
phone down to staying connected to want
to be intimate I have to go to war
against those things because I can't go
to Oregon's her because I love her too
much
and so it does injustice to ADHD and OCD
it does injustice to the marriage it
doesn't Justice to the people you love
and it doesn't Justice to you to use
those things as excuses and so you've
heard me say this a lot those are simply
a context not an excuse
check they're just the like I wear
sunglasses and the world looks dark it's
not dark the Sun's shining I mean I it
just looks darker to me so I have to be
okay with that I have to just know
that's just the way I see the world and
experience the world
the second thing is when you have OCD
and ADHD especially we often want to
make a show of it
okay so here's an example in my house I
sat I check the locks three or four
times before I go to bed
I could make a big announcement I have
for 30 years I have forever
I could make a huge announcement
well my OCD is making me get up and go
to I just don't I just say I'll be right
back
or I just say I'm gonna run to the
basement real quick
and I'm pretty sure my wife knows what
I'm doing but maybe she has no idea and
maybe after all these issues and no I'm
not making an announcement about it I'm
just going along with the things that I
got going on
um when my mind is looping and racing
and I'm having the same conversation the
same fight the same loop-de-loopy
loop-de-loop and I know you know what
I'm talking about with that
um oh yeah
I don't announce to the house my OCD is
real bad right now
I have taken ownership of it and say
um I'm choosing to engage in these
strange one-sided conversations that I
would never have in real life right and
and so I'm trying to communicate
ownership but I don't go around the
house making proclamations about these
things
um
also it's my responsibility it's our
responsibility it's your responsibility
whether therapy exercise and nutrition
whether medication it's our
responsibility to do the work way
Upstream so that the people we love and
who interact with us aren't left trying
to hold together The Frayed edges of
the tapestry of our relationship
yeah does that make sense
yes so when you have OCD and ADHD what
are what are a couple of things that
drive your husband bananas
um
I wouldn't say it really drives some
crazy I guess that I would say since my
dad passed I would describe it as like a
flare-up like the anxiety so he wants me
to come to him and just say like
tell me when you're feeling something
because I was raised in a house where I
wasn't hurt so I had internalized a lot
um I'm at an age and a point in my
marriage we've been married almost seven
years
where
it's like I'm it's like I my dad died
and I didn't realize all these things
before
that are
not flaws in me necessarily but just
it's things like hiding like when I was
little I would physically hide a lot yep
um and now I've tried to describe to my
husband he's trying to figure out like
what's going what's going on with you or
why are you doing this and I'm trying to
explain to him like I feel like
I'm hiding
in different ways
um so what's a way so you know that you
you know that you you're someone who
Retreats what is a way that you and him
that you can stop keeping secrets for
someone with an Aces score of nine
Secrets will kill you
yeah yeah and see secrets and I'm
thinking Secrets secret actions secret
crushes secret thoughts secret hey I had
two more drinks last night than you know
about like Secrets across the board
um
and he's gonna feel like and again in
the same way that I would tell him if he
was on the phone don't tell her how to
feel
right he's gonna feel like
he is not enough of a husband he's not
trustworthy enough he's not safe enough
for his wife to feel safe with him
he's trying to explain to him not using
it as an excuse necessarily but I want
to undo these things as well he's just
seen me have points of really high
success before children like I went back
to college as an older person I had both
my boys during finals weeks I was a
straight A student and it's like then
he's seen very low lows
and he's trying to figure out what he
can do well you hold on hold on you're
the daughter do anything you're the
daughter of an of someone who struggles
addiction you're a performer
you could you could yep dude you could
pass your bar exam and give have birth
to a kid and probably finish the
marathon you've been training for you
can perform you can't be with because
being with funny is my my dad and his
whole entire family are literal
musicians and performers and yeah
actors and that's right yes so you can
perform all day and for someone like
your husband that performance looks like
accomplishment it's not for you it's
defense yeah yes and so pretend that's
right and it drives me crazy well you've
got to stop declaring civil war with
Sadie
yeah you don't have things to undo
you've got when you used to talk about
undoing think about a knot and a rope
and you're pulling so hard to try to
undo that knot
your job is to make peace open your
hands up there's a knot in the rope
we're moving on down the road we're
moving on down
you cannot undo your the abuse that
happened as a kid
you can't unwind that
you can't unwind the things that your
dad should have freaking said to you to
your his baby girl that he never said
and the more energy you spend trying to
unknot things that can't be undone
your your your kids your husband
everybody sees you flexing and pulling
and pulling and flexing and they don't
know what it is and so they're going to
create stories that it's their fault
yeah or that their mom's nuts
yeah
yeah that's me because I do want to let
go I don't know how so let me tell you
there's one way and it's the most
annoying answer I could possibly give
you and as if someone who struggles in
very similar areas as you I hate to tell
you this okay
you have to have to have to come up with
a way
a language between you and your husband
that you can have some level of
vulnerability
and it's going to be something that you
have to practice
yeah whether that's a spiral notebook
that you'll share because you can't say
it out loud you're just gonna just gonna
write it down
whether that's a weekly meeting that you
have typed out that you hand him across
a table and he reads it
and it could be everything from
I wanted to hide when you came home hot
from work the other day
we've been having sex like this and I
don't like it anymore we haven't been
having sex and I miss you is it me do
you think I'm too ugly or am I too old
or whatever whatever thoughts are going
through it you've got to figure out a
way that you can safely practice
bringing him into that conversation
and my promise to you is it's gonna feel
like somebody like you're standing naked
on a street corner like the whole you're
so exposed that every nerve in your body
is going to tell you cover up cover up
cover up
oh
and you have to give him the opportunity
to
peacefully engage with you and I'm going
to tell you right now he's going to say
the wrong stuff he's going to say stupid
stuff
oh I know we've been together long
enough I know that it's just hard for me
because we have been together for
since I was 15 years old and he's the
one person that I feel safe enough with
I don't think anybody has ever seen me
and so I think that's just been sort of
hard to navigate how to do that and he's
the only person I feel safe enough to do
that with
your second responsibility you're going
to have is to get a couple of
girlfriends that you can begin
practicing that with too
okay
and it's gonna again feel scary
um I I had a couple of buddies about a
decade ago guys that would just drink
beer and ate nachos and hung out all the
time and watched the fights and I I
actually took the step and again these
are guys I've known for years and so it
wasn't super weird it's like I just met
somebody
um but I told them
I've got to start getting some guys I
can be honest around
and I think my marriage is falling apart
or I think I'm not a good dad
and I think and they would give me their
bro wisdom some of it was incredible
some of it was just moronic and that's
that's fine the important thing was not
their wisdom was not their uh insights
the important thing was I said it out
loud in a group of people that I knew
were still gonna
be ride or die with me anyway
yeah right and so yeah that's the
healing but what you have to here here's
and here's the for the
um Neuroscience nerds out there here's
what we're doing we're teaching our body
that the things that got us killed as a
kid
um are the things that are Gonna Keep
we're teaching our body that we're safe
now
we weren't safe then
your dad was not a safe place wherever
mom happened to be was not safe the
person who sexually abused you was not
safe your husband is
yes these two women are and what we're
gonna do is we're gonna practice
setting these things down
and when you feel yourself taking them
up we're just gonna write that down and
write that down and husband here's the
deal I'm gonna practice saying things to
you and honestly if you want to have him
give me a call I'd love to talk to him
because I know it's hard on his side too
oh yeah I'd love to talk I can't imagine
yeah so he will he definitely love to
call him we are a big fan of days and
you and yeah have him give me a call
um
he's gonna have to work really hard to
not take all this personally
yeah
because every time you hold a secret he
does I know he does I know I know every
time you hold a secret in he blames
himself for not being a husband enough
or yeah um for not being creating a safe
enough space right and so he's gonna
have to
also have the courage while you're
saying your needs he's got to say his
too
yes
and you're gonna have to hear those as
well right
yeah OCD and um OCD and anxiety these
things have a way of making your needs
the only needs in town and it's a lie
because one of the great the great white
paths out of this is
um
one of the great paths out is serving
other people helping other people meet
their needs and when someone starts
putting needs your first thoughts are
what about me what about me that's just
the that's just you're racing mind
talking it's nonsense
great gift can be let me help you meet
your needs
um but again
I want to practice this I want you all
to practice practice figure it out
practice
um whether let's we're gonna put a
breakfast on the calendar we're gonna
put a lunch on the calendar I'm gonna
put a spiral notebook on your pillow and
you put it back on my pillow I'm just
gonna write some of these things down or
I can just tell you 15 minutes at night
before we go to bed or when we wake up
in the morning I'm going to tell you
these things
and they're going to come in ways
there's going to be some days when
everything's wonderful there's gonna be
waves that come through and everything
is a disaster
um
but let me say this and
I hope this finds its way into your
heart a little bit
your dad wasn't well
your dad was sick your dad struggled
hard
and I think at the end your dad loved
his little girl
and as long as you live you'll never
understand the demons he was fighting
those that told him the only way to get
through today is is more pills
open your hands to that
before you go to bed tonight I want you
to write a letter in a notebook with a
pen
it's a seven-year-old Sadie
until you're sorry you've been blaming
her for so much you've been
giving her so much to carry and it's
time for her to go play with her friends
like seven-year-olds are supposed to do
I want you to tell that seven-year-old
Sadie that you love her
Dad loved her
[Music]
it's time for her to stop defending
I'll be with you every step of the way
Sadie thanks for your call hang on the
line missing your copy you own your past
change your future you may already have
it I'ma send you a copy of it anyway and
you and your husband can read it
together
um we can start this New Journey of
practicing
teaching our body we weren't okay then
we're okay now we'll be right back
hey deloney here folks getting out of
debt and getting good sleep have
something in common intentionality when
you're working your way out of debt you
have to be purposeful you got to build
your emergency fund pay off your debt
smallest to largest and stick with it
all that stuff and when you're ready to
invest in good sleep you have to have a
plan too you got to get that early
morning sunlight you gotta exercise you
gotta cut out all this caffeine and you
gotta limit screen time and you have to
budget for a premium quality mattress
because it makes an enormous difference
and that's why I recommend dream Cloud
mattresses and for my friends on a
budget I have incredible news right now
dream cloud is offering my listeners 25
off their order plus 50 in additional
savings and why not 599 more dollars in
accessories with promo code John deloney
that's pillows luxury sheets and a
mattress protector and dream Cloud gives
you a one-year in-home trial so you can
make sure it's the right fit so it's
time to invest in good sleep have a
budget meeting with your spouse make a
plan and then go to dreamcloudsleep.com
and use code John deloney to get your
new mattress today that's
dreamcloudsleep.com and use code John
deloney
all right we are back we're gonna go out
to Chris in Mexico City como estas Chris
what are we doing
hey Dr John how are you I am doing great
man how are you
doing good doing good fantastic and so
what's up calling in from Mexico City
what's up dude yeah absolutely so
um me and my wife have been married for
just a short time now how long um so
about six months okay
yep so I'm American she's Mexican okay
um so we we did it for a while we got
married
um I moved here so that immigration
could be um
faster
um and because it was just taking a long
time so
after that we're here and immigration is
actually going a lot quicker than we
expected
so when you get married was the plan
always yeah we're gonna live in the
states
yeah okay
um how old is she so we we they're
basically from day one how old is she is
20 20. how old are you
21 41 where'd y'all meet
uh we just met online we just met online
where was your first where was your
first meeting
uh in Mexico okay
so you met her online y'all had a couple
of times together did you move down
before you were married or did you all
get married and then moved down
uh so I moved down maybe a couple weeks
before but not really working like I
mean this is living together but like in
separate rooms and stuff uh okay so
um
cool so how long have you lived in
Mexico together now
um yeah basically six months okay
basically and you guys thought it's
gonna be a couple years and all of a
sudden it's like oh it's time to go
yeah well maybe a year or a year and a
half yeah and so now we're kind of like
oh what the heck and she really
struggles with it because she's really
close with her family yeah absolutely
like she even like she'll get emotional
it's like she doesn't doesn't see them
for like a week or like maybe five days
yeah she'll start like crying and just
be really sad I want to see him again so
I kind of knew this day was always
coming like like it would be it would be
really hard but now it's kind of sooner
and I don't know how to support her
I think first getting out of your head
that this is going to be a day
yeah this is gonna be a long long long
time
okay she's gonna be grieving a
her family her culture the language the
food the smells the the Trap and
everything about her life is about to
change and she's 20. she's still a kid
yeah and
um
what I would tell you is you can't be
upset that she's feeling drawing and
Drawn to her family over this new life
that she had imagined and now suddenly
staring her in the face right
uh I would honor that distress and that
um
that apprehension it's very real very
true and if she's she's going to be very
very sad she's gonna have periods of
grief deep grief she's gonna go through
periods of her feelings are gonna be
highly depressed
um that's gonna happen and it's gonna
happen for a season and so I think
settling into that's gonna be really
tough my wife
to be with me she's giving up every
thing
insert like do you get the humility
there I mean that's a such a massive
thing she's giving up
all of her life everything she knows for
this dude she met and so her body's
screaming at her don't do this right so
I I guess there's a making peace with it
it just is right and she's not bad she's
not broken she's not dysfunctional
you're not bad you're not broken this is
just a tough situation for two young two
young star-cross lovers right
yeah
um do y'all have a moving date yet
nope we are still in the end processes
of immigration so it's not it's not done
it's just it's just coming
when you say that are you talking 30
days 90 days six months what are you
talking about probably about 90 days
yeah okay okay how many days to maybe
four months I don't know okay
um question number one is I would have a
steady repeated conversation with her
probably every morning
it starts something like how can I best
love you today
yeah I had that conversation
and okay it might change day to day to
day like I need you near me and I need
to hold you right now can we do that
yeah absolutely
um I need you to get out of the house
and not look at my face cool like right
you're gonna think I thought in the
mornings we hugged today is not gonna be
that day right
um yeah the grief is gonna it's gonna be
like waves in the ocean it's gonna be
some real low valleys real high peaks
and it's going to be disorienting for
you like being on a boat out in the
ocean it's gonna feel disorienting
um just just know that's coming that way
um
I would give her a figure out a safe A
place to have safe discussions about
some very concrete plans
we're going to move on this date let's
go ahead and put one on the calendar
what do you want to do in the 90 days
between now and when we are heading out
what do you want to do in the 70 days
between now you see what I'm saying
yeah I want to see if we can put that
date on the calendar even if it's going
to move let's go ahead and put on the
calendar and if it moves great cool
um just so it's like kind of real that
that's what we're doing we're trying to
make it very very real right now it's
still
um anxiety operates in a fantasy in this
futuristic Could Happen could happen
it's gonna happen might happen let's put
some things down and the body has a
remarkable way of responding when things
are imminent
like you hear people super anxious about
flying anxious about flying anxious
about flying
um and then you hear people who survive
a plane CR like planes going down they
don't say they were anxious they don't
say they were terrified they say they
were really sad like the body like oh
this is happening and there's there's
just ways body takes care of itself in a
pretty remarkable way let's see about
putting something on the calendar and I
would not do that and say this is when
we're going I would invite her into that
conversation yeah
um dates times on this day what time
would you want to leave would you want
to leave before breakfast or after
breakfast
would you want to leave after dinner
before dinner
um what do you want the night before to
be to look like you wanna have a big
party you wanna like let's start making
some very concrete reality and I want
you to hold some very open-handed space
for her looking at you saying I can't do
this have you thought through that
um I have a little bit what happens when
that happens
it's kind of scary to me because I mean
the same thing things that she'd be
she's going through I'd be going through
at the same time so
what's the likelihood give me a
percentage out of 100 that she says I I
thought I could make the move but I
can't
um like 10 20 okay so not a lot
no I think she'll go but like I'm not
100 sure you know
that's got to be scary to me because I
like I know I listen to your show a lot
so I know that she can change her mind
and that's what we discussed from day
one and stuff which is it's also hard on
me yeah
um you're probably gonna feel a lot of
guilt and shame that you're taking her
away from all the stuff to go live this
other life is it you know what I'm
saying
um
I would do my best to not hold on to
that to feel it to notice that it's
there I'm feeling guilty right now
we both as as young adults agreed on
this and so
um I'm not gonna I I'm not gonna hold
shame over this I I might feel guilty my
body's gonna do what it's going to do
but we're gonna go do the next right
thing
um is there some things that y'all can
talk through about what would make
Landing in the states
more uh hospitable more of a safe a soft
Landing if you will
like the actual dare like like just
things in place I'm talking about month
one month two month three those who I've
talked to who who move
straight from Mom's home dad's home to
the states it's so disorienting what we
call normal life is so insane from the
pace and the speed and the volume and
the sound everything is madness
um yeah have y'all talked about soft
land
yeah I definitely want to like surround
her with other people yeah from other
other Mexican people especially
um so that she can feel a little bit at
home
and so that she like doesn't feel so
disoriented like she can figure like the
supermarket the Mexican supermarket down
the street or whatever Super Mercado
but hold on I would do all that let me
tell you this
um
I think it's very important for you to
invite her into this conversation and as
a white American to not try to curate
her experience
okay because she may come over here and
say hey the more time I spend at the
supermarket or in this thing like I
can't breathe because all I can think
about is my family I need to spend a
season just going to Kroger
yeah right um and it may be no no these
things give me
um they they let me exhale when I go
into so I would invite her to maybe you
sit down and say some of the questions
some of the things you were thinking oh
hey I was thinking if
we took salsa dancing lessons or if we
ate at such and such restaurant or if
you we went to a Hispanic serving church
or whatever
um that you would feel more at home but
that's just me trying to put stuff on
you what do you think what do you
think's gonna land right and you may be
all prepped ready to go and then she
goes once and she's like no I'm not ever
doing that again right and I think it's
just holding it with a really open hand
there can you do that yeah for sure so
the soft Landing would be me not trying
to curate her experience more of just
her
um her being in the conversation how are
we going to do this yeah I think it's um
here's some here is some questions here
are some opportunities
um and maybe even
um
maybe even asking the question how how
I can work really hard I want to love
you as best I can would love look like
me trying to find as many opportunities
for you to be both uh culinary cultural
um education like do you want you want
to try to recreate home here because
I'll work my butt off and try to make
that happen I'll find the the
restaurants the the supermarkets the
cultural events I'll do whatever we can
or do you want to
um
just close that door for a season that
door will open at some point make no
mistake but I want to close that door
for a season I want to jump in both feet
and try to figure out how Publix works
and why y'all are driving on that side
of the road I want to try to figure out
all that stuff and so and just inviting
her in but but with an eagerness to I
want to help this you navigate this
experience the as best as humanly
possible and I'm open to all of it you
see the the difference there being she's
not moving into another dad who's just
going to make her do some things see
what I'm saying
yeah it's very much a spirit and she may
say I don't care you do you you've been
there you do what's best you tell me
awesome say okay cool I'm gonna do this
and then in two weeks we're checking
back in
I want you to tell me everything you
didn't like about everything you did
like about it what made you gave you
peace what made you feel anxious let's
let's check back in and I think your
tendency is probably going to be to try
to own all of it you can't you can
invite her in and um
man I wish you guys the best I hope the
transition is going to be Rocky it's
gonna be tough it's going to be full of
tears it's gonna be full of
heartbreak but man I hope I hope it goes
well I think is the more you keep your
hands open and the more you invite her
in to be a part of what happens next
that's the best chance your your
relationship has and by the way for
everybody listening this is for every
move every job transition every new kid
that comes along
sitting down and saying how can I best
love you in this new season and hang on
because that season's going to change
again and that season's Gonna Change
again how can I best love you in this
new season and invite each other into
that conversation don't just start
dictating
that is the road to transforming your
marriage we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here
I fell through a glitch in The Matrix
this is my job I get to have this show
do this show walk alongside each one of
you as a career this is what I do and I
have a blast doing it and me and the
team were so thankful for all of you for
being a part of our show whether you're
one of the original 17 or you're one of
the millions that's come since then we
are so grateful for you and we want to
put together the best possible show that
we can so if you're one of The Originals
or if you're brand new we want your
feedback tell us what you love about the
show what you hate about the show what
you'd like to see more of what you like
to hear more of and what you want us to
never do again you can email us at
askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's ask
John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right all right hey uh Jenna Kelly's
not here today so that means we can go
crazy I still want my job can't go too
crazy fun Ruiner all right let's go to
bed let's go to Kansas literally let's
go to Bethany out in Kansas what's up
Bethany
hi Dr John how are you doing partying
dude how are you
I'm good just chilling out in the cold
weather here in Kansas
how cold is it today
well it says 40 but it's been cloudy and
just gloomy and rainy for several days
now so that just sounds gross yeah it's
been that way here in Nashville and the
sun came out today so hang in there it's
coming it's coming
okay so what's up how can I help
um so my question for you today is
um really just so I'm
only in my second long-term relationship
and um I just you know I gain a lot of
advice from everybody around me um but
it's always terrible Bethany you know
that
is I guarantee you it's not the it's not
it's the worst how old are you
I am 36. okay you just said the way you
said this is my second long-term
relationship you said it as though
something's wrong with you do you think
that
you know I've questioned that through
the years what um
uh because I'm you know in my mid-30s
and I just had my first long-term
relationship when I was 34 so I was just
kind of what happened with that I know
what happened with that one
uh
how old was
how old was 33
so he was looking I I just by the end of
it I was just feeling more like his mom
than anything good for you gross don't
kiss your son yuck good yeah it was it
was not great all right a quick aside
men grow up okay now we're back Bethany
geez 33. unbelievable okay so if you met
somebody new
gross
he's wonderful oh gross okay
why what makes him wonderful
um he's a grown-up
part for people we relying on a lot of
things
um that are very like core values for
for me and for him
and uh we've done a lot of talking the
serious talks
um and we've been together for six
months
and we're starting to talk not really
even starting we've you know talked
about future and what all that looks
like so my question really is like how
do you know really when you're ready to
ride or die as you say with somebody and
um like best practices to prepare for
like marriage well that's a good
question
um the very unhollywood truthful answer
is
when I decide from this day forward I'm
gonna wake up every day and choose to
love this person
I wish there was like this like when
they crossed this magic threshold and
people will tell you all kind of stupid
things that they've got on posters in
their Church office or stitched into
some pillow at the Grandma's house
whatever
love is a decision it's a choice that I
make every day sometimes multiple times
a day
and my wife makes it sometimes minute by
minute right
um so it's it's really when you say it
I'm parking the bike here for the ride
or die analogy I'm parking the bike here
and this is where I'm gonna be
and so that leads me to the next there's
a couple of questions that I always like
and they're little they're a little
untraditional they wrap up some of the
stuff that you would hear in normal
normal like is he the one or is all that
kind of stuff
um the first question I always want to
know from a couple
is where do y'all go in times of
disconnection or distress
here's why like from each other from
life
are you somebody who when there's an
awkward conversation at work you
disappear
do you get loud and start swinging do
you freeze and just freeze up
um does it happen in a romantic
relationship does it happen with kids
does it happen with the person at the
grocery store here's why we often try to
solve the fighting or the hiding or the
yelling and we don't realize that it's
the exact same core issue it's just your
your body does one thing and my body
does another
and so what you often get in a
relationship a a romantic relationship
is there's an issue the issue is you
came home and said hey we were going to
talk about the budget and there's a 400
expense at some ammo store not that
that's ever happened in my life and and
instantly you have a deep a defensive
mechanism that just kicks in maybe it's
fighting maybe it's getting really loud
and pissed off maybe it's hiding
it is I'm stuck going to bring this up
I'm not going to say anything and I'm
going to let the slow Ash of resentment
burn he on the other hand when you bring
it up gets real defensive this is my
money I work hard at it and he's gonna I
wanna know where each of us go during
times of disconnection and distress
and here's the the key here is when my
what and I I am somebody who I I kind of
toggle which is weird it's rare
um sometimes I I my chest comes up and I
start to start to fight and sometimes I
hide my wife she pulls away that's just
that's just the way it goes now I know
when she starts to pull away her body's
telling her she's not safe
it's not because she's got some
character issue or some flaw it's that
her body's trying to protect her and I
can then go to the mirror and say what
am I bringing to this that makes the
house feel unsafe
see what I'm saying usually it's I'm
being Reckless with spending or I'm
I've got bull I walk in with bags of
gummy candy and she just knows oh no
he's about to fall off the wall right so
it's it that's that's question number
one question number two is
how do you tell how asking each other
how do you like to hear things that you
probably don't want to know
and this ranges from
hey you have a booger in your nose do
you want me to make a joke about it do
you want me to say it very discreetly do
you want to just not know
to here's how many people I've slept
with
two here's how many people
um I don't I don't like it like when
we're having sex I don't like it when
you do this versus when you do that like
how do you want to hear things are going
to be hard to hear the way you talked to
me last night when you were mad makes me
want to leave this house how do you want
to hear those things and let's try to do
our best to can I honor that
if somebody says I don't ever want you
to tell me I don't ever want to know you
might say I'm gonna tell you so this
this might not be a great relationship
um or like my instinct is to make jokes
about things
that's just how I handle uh hard
situations that's really helpful when
I'm going into a crisis situation and
somebody's passed away and there's
really hard things to see and then we
can make a really
dark black humor joke and almost can
kind of
like giggle through it right
um I learned early on my wife didn't
like me going oh you know what I would
love to do right now kiss you except you
got a booger on your face like she
didn't that
that hurt her feelings that was that
wasn't cool what she would like me to
say is to whisper into your hangout
booger right there
just be really matter of fact and direct
facts to your friends just say it and
then we move on I had to learn that new
language right but when she said can you
do it like this I was like absolutely I
could do that that wasn't a big deal to
me okay so how do you tell each other
things you probably don't want to hear
that's number two number three the the
big ones the role of religion money and
sex in the in their our
our relationship how do you deal this
personally how are we gonna do those
things here
um and here's the big one how do each of
you respond when those things change not
if but when
my relationship with faith is very very
different today than it was when I
started dating my wife drastically
different there's been seasons of me
being a devout atheist like just almost
Prof like proselytizing and there's been
Seasons when
um so in tune with
my faith and belief that um it's hard
there's there's not a lot of space for
anybody else and my wife has been
through ups and downs in her particular
Journeys we've just we all chose at the
beginning to hold those things really
Loosely it's not my job to make sure she
believes everything I believe but that
works for us some people couldn't do
that
right and so what's the role of religion
what's the role of money for me money is
very scary
for my wife it's this amazing
opportunity
and so we respond to it differently we
spin differently we save differently so
what's the role it plays same with sex
um so you see what I'm saying the what's
the role of religion money and sex and
then here's the last one what's the role
of kids in extended family
this does has um this guy that's just so
wonderful gross Bethany
um has he uh has he been married before
yeah
that was kind of like a side question
too that I had um but because he has a
23 year old daughter
um and she
like how it's like I know I don't really
have a say in their relationships
but as we do point to this like
situation she does depend on him
financially quite a bit and she's kind
of got her and her Grandpa like sort of
wrapped around her finger in that and uh
and and I'm looking at the future of
like you know if we extend the Family
expand the family like how how do we
have that conversation how do I have
that conversation or I don't know
[Music]
that conversation sounds less about he
can't afford it or less about there's
things we want to do together for our
dreams but he's still paying for an
adult and it sounds more like I know
that grubby little girl I've I've seen
her before and she's just taking this
man's money it sounds much more personal
than financial
yeah
ah Bethany you're my favorite call I've
had in a while
um
so that's going to be a you issue not
him
where it's going to be a him issue is if
you find yourself quietly low simmer
disrespecting him because he's still
paying for her
right if you have a hard time with the
way that he if you think you're going to
gently steer him away from his daughter
you're not going to You're Gonna you're
gonna cause havoc
yeah and I don't I don't want to do that
I know you don't I know you don't I know
you don't but you also want her to grow
up I've seen girls like her like you
want that too
um yeah I think that's that's going to
be a place where
probably bite your tongue on that one
where it will come up is when you start
to say okay when we have this
conversation about the role of religion
the role of money the role of sex that's
really a role of what kind of Life do we
want to live
and in 20 years when you're 56 and
you're 58 what house do you want to have
what town do you want to live in where
do you want to be and there's no
guarantee we're ever going to get there
but at least at least aim at something
and begin formulating a plan let's
reverse engineer plan to get there and
that's when it's like hey you've still
sent a thousand dollars a month to your
23 year old kid that's a lot tell me
about that and it's probably gonna be he
feels guilty over some divorce and he
still feels like he needs to fund this
thing because he's paying this out of
guilt and that happens all the time and
he's gonna have to come to the choice
that he doesn't want to do that
yeah
yeah there's I feel like there's a lot
of guilt in it of course there almost
always is almost always is
um there's also
um have you taken her out for coffee
just to get to know her
not one-on-one not yet it's still been
kind of a
get to know her with
with him around and so
she hasn't is your dad still around
huh is your dad still around
are you fully you around your dad and
and your boyfriend
no you were not
uh my father-in-law's in town and I wore
a long sleeve shirt just to convert my
tattoos and it's my house in my house
just out of respect just trying to be
respectful and so
um I tell you that to tell you you're
not getting to know her with her dad
around
right you're getting to see how she how
she curates Her Image when old man's
around but you don't know her
um I I would I would lean in there
because you're gonna find a lot about
her
um you're gonna find some stories about
him that you don't know
um you're gonna find out a lot about how
she's been raised how she's operated and
for both really good and you're gonna
have some like whoa I didn't know all
that and that's part of the picture that
you are choosing to opt into if you're
with this guy and I think that's I think
that's amazing it's just you just want
to make sure
the car looks great I just want to drive
it first
and what role does your family play
three hours away so
they're just kind of
their advisors a lot of the times but
I'm talking about Christmas Thanksgiving
holidays birthdays funerals
yeah those are important to us and and
that's a that's a difference in our my
family versus his is like it's not
really a thing with his family because
it's a he has such a small family
um but for my family like it's a big
thing let's have all those conversations
up what's the role of kids in extended
family
does that sound good
hey I'm proud of you
for asking these fun hard questions
well thank you for
for the ask these fun hard questions
it's your life you do whatever you want
I here's the one thing I would challenge
you and him on I would create a spirit
of Adventure when you're asking these
questions not a spirit of Law and Order
SVU inquiry in court
what's how do you believe how do you
function with religion what is your
thoughts on sex that's so like geez I'm
not gonna fight you now my defense
mechanisms are coming up
but if we're going on an adventure
together hey we're thinking about
building a life
what's the role of faith and religion
plays in your world
um is this scientific method something
you worship or is it a cool way to solve
science problems like like tell me about
what you believe tell me about what you
think what's the role of money plays in
your life did you have a lot growing up
did you have none growing up like let's
let's have a spirit of Adventure about
these questions and by the way every one
of these questions will change
ta-da that's the big secret nobody tells
you about they'll all change and so the
second question here is probably one of
the most important ones how do I tell
you things that you probably don't want
to hear
you don't want to know that I used to
love it when you did this thing in bed
and then four months went by and I hate
I hate and now you think it's the
greatest move it's your best move
embarrass it for four months you've been
coming in and doing this thing how do we
have those conversations because it's
gonna shift it's going to shift and it's
gonna move and that is the Grand
Adventure of being married to somebody
and it's not something to be scared over
to run away from it's something to
embrace fully and be like oh awesome I
get to have a never-ending adventure
with somebody it's fantastic what a what
a bad way to live it's awesome hey hang
on the line Bethany I'm gonna send you
the questions for humans for dating
couples and for romantic couples gross
and um those can be on me I want y'all
to go through them you'll have a blast
hey thanks for the call we'll be right
back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we are back hey this is in
it's celebration time my book own your
past change your future is having its
one year anniversary today thousands of
lives have been changed people have been
picking this book up all across the
world and I'm so grateful this book is
my way of sitting with you one-on-one
just us and some nachos ain't right and
talking through life offering practical
advice and encouraging you on topics
like relationships trauma why the
world's gone sideways and most
importantly what what do we do about it
right in celebration of the one year
anniversary of the book I want to give
you the own your past change your future
audiobook ebook and my key talk this is
the Genesis of the book a talk I gave to
about 3 000 Business Leaders I think we
were in Orlando and it it touched a
nerve in a way that I I did not
anticipate and it ended up being the
Genesis of the book I'm going to give
you a copy of that talk for free when
you buy a hardcover copy of own your
pass change your future sir
this deal is for today only it ends at
11 59 PM central time all right so today
only I'm going to give you all that
stuff if you pick up a copy if you or
one of the people who haven't picked it
up yet this is the perfect time if
you're gonna buy for Christmas or for
the holidays whatever this is the moment
okay this book is not just for people
healing from trauma this is for
everybody I've heard from single moms
I've heard from multi multi multi
multi-millionaires I've heard from
police officers I've heard from veterans
I've heard from everybody in between
everybody who's looking around the world
going what in the world is going on
so get your copy and all these freebies
today before the deal ends at midnight
go to John deloney.com deal d-e-a-l John
deloney.com
deal and
in honor of caller from Kansas and my
brothers and sisters from the K-State
song is from the great Kansas Carry On
Wayward Son goes like this carry on my
wayward son there will be peace when
you're done
lay your weary head to rest
don't you cry no more Kelly that's what
you always tell me don't cry no more
once I Rose above the noise and
confusion just to get a glimpse Beyond
this illusion I was soaring even higher
but I flew too high
Kelly gets too high though my eyes could
see I was still a blind man though my
mind could think I was still a Madman I
hear the voices when I'm Dreaming I can
hear them say
carry on my wayward son I tell you all
keep taking the next step it's down the
path you got this we'll see you soon
thank you